who's that sliding into your Twitter DMS
is it the federal government well
according to Elon Musk who took over the
social media platform last year
government bureaucrats were routinely
taking a close look at users content
here's what Elon told Fox news's Tucker
Carlson the degree to which various
government agencies had effectively had
full access to everything that was going
on on Twitter blew online I was not
aware of that would that include
people's DMs
uh yes thanks to the Twitter files a
collaboration between Elon Musk and
independent journalists as well as the
Facebook files my own investigative
project for reason we now know that
social media companies constantly face
pressure to censor speech net pressure
was coming from the government the state
department the Department of Homeland
Security the FBI even the White House
they all targeted legitimate online
speech federal law enforcement agents
flagged tweets and posts for deletion
under the guise of protecting National
Security and no one should be surprised
the feds love to invoke National
Security and then take away more of your
rights and pretend they're keeping you
safe well guess what they're at it again
following a massive leak of U.S
intelligence documents that were posted
on Discord another social media platform
the Biden Administration wants more
power to monitor online chat rooms a
senior Administration official told NBC
news that the government quote is now
looking at expanding the universe of
online sites that intelligence agencies
and law enforcement authorities track
that's bad we know where it will lead
more government surveillance of the
American people and eventually more
censorship of political speech in the
run-up to the 2020 election for example
the FBI warned social media sites to be
wary of russian-based disinformation but
then they also started flagging joke
tweets written by Americans that
happened to be about the election you
see the feds just can't help themselves
they'll use the new powers we give them
to pressure the internet to shut down
dissent we've seen it happen time and
time again so let's keep the government
out of our chat rooms and watch out for
your DMs
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]